good morning everybody welcome to cloud
on air these are your live webinars that
we're hosting every single Tuesday for
the month of February
I'm your host Evan Jones and today we're
gonna be talking about what can you
build with Google cloud in ten minutes
or less so first give me a little bit of
background about myself and also our
team behind the scenes here to answer
your questions any time during the
session here so I'm a technical
curriculum developer on the Google cloud
team and I specialize in building data
and machine learning courses I'm
extremely excited to be here with you
all today to give you a sense of what
you can do on Google cloud but behind
the scenes we also have a team of a
moderation panel Barry one of my good
friends who's gonna be help answering
your questions live that you can post
any time during this session right below
this window so let's talk a little bit
about what we're gonna be learning today
so first up I'm gonna give you about a
15 minute lecture in what we're gonna be
doing for the Google cloud platform
specifically we're gonna be spinning up
a VM instance and launching a web server
hopefully with under 10 minutes to spare
so you all watching can keep me
accountable and we're also gonna be
doing a live question-and-answer session
at the end but that doesn't mean you
have to hold your best questions until
the end of the webinar feel free to type
them live and we get answered at any
time by our moderation team so let's go
ahead and get started
ultimately I'm here to help you start
out your Google cloud journey today so
if you've never heard of Google cloud or
you've heard of cloud technologies but
you haven't got a really a chance to get
experienced with launching a virtual
machine or you've heard a lot of these
acronyms and you don't know where to
start
you're exactly in the right place so
today what we're gonna be doing is three
different things we're gonna set up in
your interactive quick labs environment
a virtual machine that's gonna be
launching a web server and again I'm
gonna shoot that in the audacious goal
of 10 minutes or less and then what you
can do later on is this is just gonna be
one lap I like to call it the tip of the
iceberg there's gonna be 7 labs and what
we call the Google cloud platform
essentials quest which is just a series
of different labs
our lab environment platform so later on
today or tomorrow we're going to give
you free credits so you can take the
rest of the labs at your leisure so this
is just to continue your training at
your own pace and after that if you're
really getting sued and we hope you will
you can also take more training and if
you want to hear the more sounds of my
voice and my other training can Patriots
here you can go to cloud.google.com
slash training and take some more
on-demand online courses through
Coursera or sign up for a local course
as well but let's get started so as I
mentioned our primary goal today I don't
really like to do a lot of talking so
I'd like to give you a interactive live
demo of exactly what we're gonna be
doing and you can follow along in the
labs environment that we're gonna be
showing you soon
so ultimate end goal we want to spin up
a web server on a virtual machine box
ten minutes or less let's see if we
can't do it get ready to follow along so
if there's any slide that I want you to
pay attention to it's this one
so in the the chat below you're gonna
have this link as well but if you don't
type into your browser now google.com or
sorry goog goog L / PB v WP L making
sure to note the capitals and this is
how you're gonna get 20 free lab credits
just for showing up today so this will
start you off on our labs environment
inside of quick labs and all of our is
sandbox student accounts and
instructions for these labs are hosted
within this platform so I'm gonna leave
that up there for just a few more
seconds while you take that down or
click on it from below
once you're there I want you to browse
the quests so in the upper left hand
corner if you're not already there that
little rectangle with a bunch of other
squares inside of it that's your lab
catalog for quick labs click on that
then click on quests and then find the
one marked GCP essentials so as you
notice there's a ton of different tracks
that you could take for these quests so
you're interested in data and machine
learning or a bunch of these other
different topics that are there like
kubernetes for example or MLA P is well
those are a little bit more advanced
we're gonna start out with the
bare-bones basics which is setting up
Google compute engine to process things
in a virtual machine click on GCP
essentials now in order to redeem
20 free credits and these are lab
credits click on enroll in this quest
and a quest again is just a collection
of in this particular case seven
different labs and in today's session
we'll just be going through that first
one which is creating your very first
virtual machine so enroll in the quest
click on the creating virtual machine
lab you'll be prompted with this modal
that says lab access costs 1 credit and
you should see something that says if
you went through that link and you
enrolled in that that you have 20
credits available go ahead and spend one
of those credits to launch in this
particular lab now I'll ask you not to
start the lab yet because we're gonna be
doing it together a little bit later but
if you're having any technical issues
whatsoever in getting to this page
ultimately it'll look like this with
that green start lab button just aching
to be pressed if you can't get to this
page be sure to type into the chat below
and we have Jade and Barry here to help
you out from the quick lab side and our
side at Google to help you out pause on
that page because that's when your lab
instructions that we're gonna be going
through it together
and once you a little bit about the
quick labs environment why we're asking
you to log into quick labs instead of
using your own Google cloud platform
account if you don't have a Google cloud
platform account or if you didn't want
to use your your own personal account
these are free sandbox accounts with
these credits that we've given you and
what happens it'll automatically create
this email address and password for you
and then it will open up the console for
you for a predetermined period of time
in this particular case the lab is live
for 30 minutes so one of the things I'll
ask you to do all the way on the on the
don't side there is if you when if and
when you do start the lab don't click
and lab prematurely because that will
shut down all of your resources as well
and we'll go through this when we
actually go through the lab together but
in one tab in your browser just be sure
that you have that open as well okay I
promised you that I'm gonna be a very
short lecturer so we have about five
minutes of topics to cover on the cloud
in general and then we're gonna jump
into doing this lab together and you
guys can tie me to see if we can do it
in 10 minutes or less alright one of my
favorite topics to talk about before my
career here at Google I was a freelance
web designer and web developer and I
ended up wearing a ton of different hats
so although I really like to
and make these beautiful graphics and
images and design a beautiful UI for
this site ultimately it came time to
answer the question of where am I gonna
host this where am I gonna store this
data if folks are uploading things to my
site where are those ultimately getting
it stored it's in addition to having it
his design hat on or if you're writing
software programs having your
programming hat on which is what you
really want to focus on back in the day
you also had to be almost like a
hardware engineer or an infrastructure
engineer just to make sure that you had
enough storage for all the things that
you're looking to store and serve you
had enough compute power if you're
running a lot of compute and
computational jobs or if you just had
any kind of computations for your
applications you need to make sure that
you had a big enough server or CPU to
process that also for latency do you
have enough networking and last but not
least if a server disk fails or there is
an operating system update that needs to
be installed you also need to be kind of
a DBA or an infrastructure technician to
make sure that all of your hardware is
running smoothly so you warm many of
these different hats and we all know a
jack of all trades master of none it's
not in your best interest to be focused
on infrastructure and when ultimately
want to be focused on building at the
latest and greatest business software
whatever it is that your business is
looking to do so what happened in the
last ten years
so back when I was building websites I
had to buy or rent out a box a server
that's sitting in my closet somewhere to
ultimately stir up these web pages and
have to go in and manually install
software updates and operating system
updates where has that space gone so all
the way on the Left DC there is the
datacenter we're managing all this stuff
myself we call it on-premise or physical
or your or your co-located there and
eventually it moved into well everyone
else is having the same problem we all
don't want to buy these boxes and even
if we're perfectly good at maintaining
them and we're experts at hardware a lot
of times the machines are sitting unused
and we're still paying for electricity
costs even when they demand on our say
our website isn't that high until you
Black Friday comes along and then
coincidentally we don't have enough
server capacity so it's hard to manage
the ups and the downs and we just have a
static amount of hardware so what that
generally shifted to was a
virtualization environment where we
could rent out time in these machines
but you would still be responsible for
installing and managing and
dealing with all the maintenance
headaches that that went there in as
well so what is ultimately happened with
this big push to cloud so all the way in
the right you see that it's the catch
phrase is that it's service it's fully
automated so unless you really liked
managing that Hardware yourself with it
a lot of people didn't they really
wanted to focus on their core competency
which is building amazing software
models designing incredible website and
application experiences you no longer
need to worry about infrastructure it's
fully managed and in the example that I
gave where Black Friday you might not
have enough servers and then if there's
a slow Monday or Tuesday you have way
too much capacity so you're wasting time
and you have the opportunity cost of
service sitting there you want this more
of the inelastic scalable when you need
it and it scales down when you don't and
that's exactly what a Google cloud
platform comes into play so Google cloud
platform I like to say Google's been
doing cloud for more than 10 years but
you just heard of it recently it's
because Google has been running its own
private cloud because they ultimately
had to solve the exact same problems
that you've had to solve which is if
you're gonna be organizing all the
world's information and making it
accessible to everybody around the world
Google had to solve this hardware
problem for itself and so they invested
millions of dollars in infrastructure
and building these undersea cables that
you see here for networking and these
data centers all around the world
including edge locations to make sure
that your Google's web pages and search
queries can be accessed anywhere
throughout the world so as they like to
say don't reinvent the wheel if Google's
already got the infrastructure in place
and it's good enough for things like
Gmail Google photos and any of the other
Google applications and answering your
search queries it's gonna be good enough
for your applications as well so this
was ultimately make what makes Google
Google and only recently in the last
five years or so Google has made that
hardware that infrastructure available
to you all for your use in what's called
the Google cloud platform so say I've
convinced you on cloud you might be
faced with a lot of different product
choices or icons and you might not be
sure where to start so okay
I've got the idea that it's a platform
but I don't really know
should I be using App Engine should I be
using am I do I have a big data need I
need a diagram or some kind of training
to figure out where I should start and
you know that the cloud ended of itself
is elastic and scalable but the key word
that I want you to focus on for today is
that it's a platform it can be anything
that you want it to be so the key three
areas of the cloud compute doing a lot
of computational powers say you're
running a bunch of scripts or you're
serving up your applications you're
performing a lot of computation data and
analytics that's my specialty so if
you're running analysis over petabytes
of data and you want it to be done at a
blazing fast speed and you don't want to
worry about the size of your hard drive
limiting the amount of data that you can
store the platform can be use for that
as well or if you wanted to get into
machine learning and last but not least
if you want to not worry about load
balancing or any of these other typical
headaches that it comes with running an
entire infrastructure enterprise Google
cloud platform provides those product
options for you there as well but since
this is our first foray into this we're
going to focus on one of the very
fundamental building blocks I would say
there's two the first one is compute
which is what we're going to be spinning
up with our virtual machine today and
then in future sessions and webinars you
know what about Google Cloud storage
where you can actually store a lot of
that data so let's start our journey so
I promised I wouldn't talk for too long
without showing you an amazing demo so
let's jump into our lab which is
creating a virtual machine on GCP Google
cloud platform and we're gonna put a web
server software engine acts on that box
and ten minutes or less so I'll ask you
to do is right now you should have quick
labs
you've already navigated to GCP
essentials down here and we'll talk a
little bit more about these labs and
what you can do after this and in here
you'll see the seven labs that are part
of this series so if you're already
getting excited for things like oh man
we're gonna be doing kubernetes and
stackdriver as you can see on my shirt
here and then setting up load balancers
this is all part of this I like I like
to think of this as your your foundation
so I'm gonna start with this with this
first lab in this first quest again it's
the tip of the iceberg it's when I
create a virtual machine now I finally
caught up to you all playing along at
home and we're gonna actually start the
lab together
so go ahead and click on start lab now
one of the first gotchas I'm going to
say is won't you be doing part of this
lab so I'm going to ask you to click on
in the right hand side create a new
instance from the cloud console that's
going to jump us down all the way here
so if you're playing along I want you to
actually not start at the very start of
the lab you can be starting from where
the text says create a new instance from
the cloud console and we've got a little
bit over nine minutes to see if Evan
can't do this
okay so ultimately we're gonna be having
two tabs one is your lab instructions
which is what we're looking at right now
and the second we actually need to get
to the cloud so to get to the cloud we
need to open the cloud console I'm just
gonna click on this yellow button here
and here's the second gotcha
the first gotcha is if you're not
starting in the same place I am in the
lab a lot of what I'm gonna be doing is
gonna look very strange and the second
gotcha is when you're prompted is sign
in with your Google Cloud account be
sure you go back to quick labs and copy
the auto-generated username that you see
there I'm gonna paste that in and again
a lot of times when we see these Google
signings we automatically type in if you
have your account already you might just
type in your personal account but that
would defeat the point of having this
sandbox environment now your accounts
may be different than mine and once
you're taken to this screen you accept
the Terms of Service don't worry about
setting up any Recovery Options and once
you've accepted the additional Terms of
Service you should be taken to a screen
like this if you're taken to a screen
that says choose your project and it has
a quick labs - resources and then quick
laps - GCP and some alphanumeric
characters be sure that you're on the
quick clubs now gzp with the
alphanumeric characters because you're
autumn automatically generate a Google
cloud platform account so you should
already give yourself as a pat on the
back because now you've actually
accessed the Google cloud platform so
when you or your company or your friends
are working in GCP this is what they say
that they mean so you have a bunch of
different products and services that you
can open up on the left side menu here
and what we're going to be focusing on
today is spinning up a virtual machine
so go ahead and click on compute engine
and these are exactly following the
steps of the lab as well now we have a
bunch of different options the default
one
is what instances of a virtual machine
do we have go ahead and click on create
cuz we don't have any so far it's gonna
prompt you with a couple of different
options there's a lot of custom machine
types and you can specify the zone and
the size of the CPU I mean they go up
from one virtual CPU to I belive 96 with
over a hundred gigabytes of RAM so you
can get some pretty big machine
instances out there I'm just gonna type
in a name you can feel free to copy this
as well GCE lab and then the most
important thing the third gotcha is
since we're gonna be creating a web
server we want folks to access that
server externally through our IP address
that's the foundation of the internet
and how the web works by allowing
hypertext Transfer Protocol or HTTP
traffic allowed just that first box not
both of them and go ahead and click on
create alright while that instance
itself gets spun up in this particular
zone should only take about a minute or
two let's revisit the lab and see what
else we have left so a little over six
minutes let's see if I can't get you
guys on a web server even ahead of time
so scrolling down in the lab you see
that we've set up the virtual machine
instance and now ultimately want what we
want to do is we need to we need to get
root access to that web server and how
you do that is we're actually going to
SSH or grant ourselves access into the
VM and I'm gonna copy this first command
onto my clipboard and I'm gonna go back
and if you see the good news with the
green check right here it means that
this instance is running so your VM is
there for you now the fourth gotcha is
I've already disabled it but sometimes
when you click on that SSH if you have a
browser where it blocks your pop-ups go
ahead and disable that and then this
window will come up and this will be a
terminal into your own instance that you
just spun up literally a minute ago so I
mean compare this to the Past again so
if you're buying servers and putting
them in your garage literally the time
to access the server and install what
you want could be days if not weeks at
7:00 Saturday up correctly and here just
in the span of 5 to 10 minutes we now
have a box that we can access so I'm
gonna route into
so just pasting that command or type it
out sudo su - and we want to make sure
that the box says the latest it by
default since we didn't change it it's
gonna be a Linux box so I'm gonna see if
there's any Debian Linux updates to the
operating system so I'm just gonna copy
the next command here in the lab which
is apt-get update so bring everything up
to do and behind the scenes it's gonna
reach out and see if there's anything
else that needs to be updated on our
operating system and after it's done
that this virtual machine is ready for
our use now before we install the nginx
web server I'm asked you to copy this to
your clipboard all you're doing is
apt-get install nginx this is the really
important command is just a one-line
command that installs a webserver what
I'd like you to do is go back to compute
engine before you install the web server
click on this IP external IP address
again this is you know every website
that's out there has an external IP
address link to it and it says that the
site can't be reached so if you have
this page you're you're doing fantastic
because ultimately we have not installed
the web server yet and nginx is just an
open source web server software that'll
allow folks to connect in through to
your box and again so we're installing a
web server but if you wanted to run
things like python scripts or doing any
kind of processing anything that you
could you would want to use a machine
for you can use a virtual machine for so
let's get back into our terminal we're
gonna install nginx after that's done
it's setting up all the tunnels while
that's running I'm gonna copy the last
command which is making sure that the
nginx process is running and we are very
near the finish line here so let's just
see if it's running good it's got master
processes for nginx so crossing your
fingers with just over three minutes to
spare
go into that tab where you have that
external IP address already there and
just for showmanship we're just gonna
reload it in this tab so if you're taken
to welcome to nginx that's the default
page for your webserver that means it's
successfully installed and you can
access it externally through that IP
address so congratulations if you've
gotten to this point if you're wondering
how I got to this IP address again go
back into compute engine click on
external IP and that will bring you here
so this is your blank slate from a VM
let's recap you've created a virtual
machine and it can be of the size if
you're choosing but by default we just
went with the default settings and with
just a few lines of the command terminal
we've opened up a web server and now you
have access to your VM instance through
the web so congratulations
alright so I'll pause here and basically
say even if your ultimate end goal was
not to create a web server you want to
run other computational jobs you want to
load up applications you want to do
batch processing on your on your data
anything that as I mentioned before that
you can use a machine for you can load
up into that virtual machine instance
now the interesting part about this is
as you're gonna learn as you move
through and through the different labs
in the series is this there's still
better and better ways of doing this
type of processing so maybe you're
thinking well Evan I don't want to root
access to a server and install operating
system software and then install
anything dealing with the terminal I
don't really don't want to do is there a
way or what are the what are the latest
and greatest technologies that prevent
me from having to even touch the
terminal and how do I manage multiple
instances of compute engine so I can
just focus on building software so if
you're interested in that type of
technology and you're really hungry to
learn more about how for example
kubernetes and in one of the labs you
can experience will actually
orchestrate and manage a lot of those
VMs for you behind the scenes then just
let this be the first part of your
journey into taking a lot of those
different labs so this is literally just
the justice start you've created your
very first we have to start somewhere so
you've created your very first VM but
that's just going to be the first step
that you're gonna take in this
particular quest all right so I'm gonna
close out of my terminal I'll ask you to
do is when you're ready you can actually
end that lab ended it with a minute to
spare and - please do rate the labs if
there's any issues that you come across
them because our team on the curriculum
development so it doesn't tries to do a
good job of creating all these exciting
and engaging labs for you all and
speaking of all the different options
that you have to further incentivize you
all since you again the world is there
for those who show up and obviously you
are doing an amazing first jobs creating
this first virtual machine here and 9:00
a.m. Pacific so we want to reward you if
in the next three or four days you
create you complete the rest of the
seven this lab so I'm assuming only did
part of it you want to complete the rest
of the creating a virtual machine lab
and the other six labs in the quest for
GCP essentials then what we'll give you
is an additional $200 in GCP credit so
for your own personal account outside of
quick labs when you're ready to actually
do this for yourself and create your own
GCP account you'll be credited in
additional two hundred bucks there to
work with
in addition honestly more valuable to
that in my personal opinion is getting
the experience with things like oh I'm I
now know how to create a virtual machine
instance and you get this recognition of
attendance and you want some pretty cool
badges as well and dare I say bragging
rights for your friends so you can say
hey I can set up a VM and ten minutes or
five minutes or less can you as I like
to say this is just the very first step
in your journey what we on the the
training team here really want our
ultimate end goal is to get you excited
about using the cloud
at the end of the day if you're a
machine learning researcher or a data
scientist or if you're someone that's
just looking to build a better website
or build a better mobile application or
a UI UX experience and you don't want to
worry about hardware you don't want to
worry about infrastructure you want to
rely on Google's security for
infrastructure and hardware but you
don't really know where to start this is
your best first step is to take these
you already have gotten familiarity with
what the Google cloud platform
looks like that's that blue dashboard
that we're looking at previously and
then these trainings go hand in hand so
if you wanted to take for example oh I'm
curious to learn more about deploying an
application you could take the deploying
applications quest you've mastered gzp
essentials you completed those seven
labs now you want to move on to machine
learning api's you want to learn how to
translate different languages classify
images if you want to learn about
orchestration of software automatically
behind the scenes you could take
kubernetes again this is I don't want to
I don't want to be prescriptive and in
designating what your learning journey
should take just start with the
foundation is the essentials here and
depending upon your businesses and
ultimately what interests you continue
on with two more quests and the new
content is added here every single month
and the labs are designed to be
interactive and exactly like the one of
the experience today all right with that
said I'm going to take a quick pause and
all the questions that you've been
writing and you furiously want to get
answered we'll come back live and we'll
choose the top questions to answer live
here in this webinar we'll be right back
you
all right well I hope you all enjoyed
the live demo and you're able to follow
along now we have a couple of live
questions from the audience
number one as you see here where do I
log into quick labs so the best place to
just keep this in the back of your mind
quick labs you'll just have to memorize
the spelling of it it's Google dot
you WI K L ABS com if you go to Google
Doc quick labs com you'll see a massive
banner that says I'm looking at here if
you go there it says real-time training
in real environments and what you can do
is browse that hands-on lab catalog now
the thing is for this webinar session be
sure to use that Google short link that
we showed you a little bit earlier that
hopefully is still stored in the chat
below because that's gonna give you
those 20 free credits so if you try to
log in and sign into quick labs through
the normal route that anybody else
outside of this webinar will use you
won't get those 20 free credits often a
question comes up as well as if you've
enrolled in this quest previously and
you say you got halfway through and you
attended this webinar and then you try
to you're wondering like hey how do I
get my 20 free credits the best thing to
do is unenroll or D enroll let's go to
say and then re-enroll and you'll get
those 20 free credits
attributed to your account as well and
again the the big honey pot at the end
is if you complete all seven of those
labs in the GCP essentials quest the
entire quest not only do you get an
awesome badge and you look really cool
but you'll get that additional $200 in
GCP credits as well you've got about
four days to do that so if you enjoy
that first lab just honestly keep moving
right through them question were - I've
never used the Google cloud platform and
I don't use G suite or Gmail can i still
take these labs well I have to setup a
Google account well the great news about
quick labs is you you don't need to you
can sign up the quick labs with any
email address that you have and even if
you have a Google email address and you
want to just use a different email
address you're more than welcome to just
sign up with whatever email that you
have and then once you actually log in
you might be asking well hey ultimately
am am I not gonna be using the Google
cloud platform don't I need a Google
account for that and that's the super
great thing about quick labs is it's our
training platform so it will
automatically create these alphanumeric
user names and passwords you'll get your
own personalized at quick labs Neb email
and generated password that you saw and
that's what as you've remember from the
demo I was copying and pasting into the
the login and then that account is live
for the durations of your labs and then
some of these labs are short like the
basic ones are 30 minutes and some of
the machine learning ones that we just
wrote earlier this year could take you
upwards of two to three hours because
they're very very advanced and they'll
hold your hand every step of the way as
you interact with not just compute but
you know five or six different products
and the GCP the Google cloud platform
project account number three I've
enrolled in a quest but still have zero
credit what else do I have to do let me
answer that a little bit with unenroll
yourself and then re-enroll yourself
making sure to ultimately use that link
because when you click on that link
there especially you are URL parameters
that actually get passed through number
five number four actually how do I get
access to these labs what does it cost
so Google dot quick labs comm bookmark
that URL and if you forget that you can
go to cloud.google.com slash training
and then these all these labs we linked
there as well then you can sign in and
sign up some of the labs that will start
you out so when the initial labs are
free but most of the labs will actually
cost credits and to get these credits
what you can do is you you purchased
them in you can purchase them
individually but there's also a bulk
discount so if you wanted to buy say a
thousand lab credits for your entire
company there is a discounting in in
bulk as well the pricing is pretty
transparent when you get into the
purchasing or accessing the lab credits
it'll prompt you to to get the credits
before you can take the lab that answer
is number five which is several of us at
the company want to take the lab in your
company account yeah I'm more than
welcome to Buy in in bulk and distribute
as well number six if I know the basics
already I've spun up VMs I'm an expert
at that's already do you have any
advanced labs and yes we do some of the
labs honestly even though some labs have
written myself last year I'll go back
into them and I'm like wait a minute at
the end of the day I have to build this
like machine learning model that like
translates three languages and like
classifies these images how on earth did
we do this again and the good news about
you know taking the labs again is it'll
take you all the way from start to fit
even though it's super complex topic if
I'm gonna throw scary words that you let
kubernetes or machine learning they're
very very accessible when you partner
with the the training and the labs that
we available to you here I'd highly
encourage you I mean I'm super biased
because I've created some of the data
and the machine learning ones but the
ones on application development
monitoring your security of your
applications there's labs there's over a
hundred labs last last I checked and a
lot of them get do get pretty advanced
but what I really would like to leave
you guys with is yeah you can take the
labs individually but the quests are
there almost in like a linear fashion so
you can go Alucard and take a few labs
oh I'm interested in kubernetes I'm
interested in more on Google Cloud
storage and kind of like manage your own
ad hoc curriculum but those the quests I
would say organize those labs in a
prescriptive order to make it a little
bit more easier for you to kind of go
through them linearly because the
concepts build on each other last place
what happens if I get stuck doing a lab
where can I get help so this is a side
plug for Coursera a lot of our courses
on our online e-learning platform for
Coursera you can go to cloud google.com
slash training and from there you can
actually access on-demand Coursera
courses which also feature these same
quick labs labs and the benefit there is
you can actually when you get stuck in a
lab Coursera has a forum for each of the
different courses that you take on there
and then course creators like myself and
other subject matter experts or smees
monitor those forums really really
actively and you can get the benefit of
students that may have already asked
your question or had an issue with that
lab in the past but at the end of the
day if you're that's for more of a I'm
struggling with the concept or this
isn't really you know I want to ask more
people about how to better understand
what's going on if you're having any
technical issues whatsoever and
regardless of whether or not you use
Coursera or not the quick labs support
team is absolutely amazing so inside of
a lab if you're if you ever run into
access issues or any kind of strange
things where your account gets deep
revision for whatever reason and the low
right on corner there's a button that
says support and you can open up a
ticket with the support team and they're
extremely good about responding in a in
a really quick fashion so I guess what
those would be the two things that I
would leave you is that is take the
trainings wherever you see them align
yourself to attract that interests you
if you want a more classroom type
experience you can take the Coursera
courses or you can even register for
in-person courses making an instructor
like me that I'll deliver it in a
physical location and in last but not
least if you have any issues with the
labs from a technical level use that
support ticketing system as well let's
see another question that I would leave
you with last bits of advice
so before I lose you guys honestly it's
getting the opportunity to come up here
and teach you even just the basics of
spinning up a virtual machine it's not
about the tools or technology it's about
the willingness and the excitement that
you all have to tune in 9:00 a.m.
Pacific time on a Tuesday morning to
even attempt something like this so like
I said briefly in the webinar earlier
the world is there for those who show up
I myself didn't learn a lot of these
concepts from a textbook it's a lot of
on-the-job training so if you're in an
organization that is we could range the
spectrum of interested in cloud but
unsure of where to start or you're
already using cloud and you're pretty
deep on the technical scale you're gonna
find these trainings there for you and
my only piece of advice is is don't be
afraid to to fail so much like the best
machine learning algorithms are built
upon many many many thousands of
iterations of failure until you find the
one that works it's the same way with
learning so so the good news about these
Labs laws be or be there for you and
just honestly have a blast and it try to
try to break them if you can find a lab
with with a way that you would do it
better submit a submit a support ticket
and then hopefully you'll get a message
from me saying hey you didn't an awesome
job and correcting this or I love the
direction that you're taking it as well
but I mean the last two words of the
lady would says just have fun with it
the cloud technology is evolving and I'm
sure five years from now we're giving
these new webinars for you and the rest
of the webinars you take throughout the
day today and every Tuesday here in
February are just gonna give you a taste
of some of the technology that's out
there here at Google for you to use on
Google cloud platform but the space is
is phenomenally growing and it's
ever-changing as well so keep yourself a
fresh so with the latest updates that
are coming and more importantly than
that keep practicing with these hands-on
labs all right well that does it for me
here in the studio in Mountain View
California I want you to stay tuned for
your next session which arguably has an
even more exciting title than mine which
is what is love applying machine
learning to help win the hearts of your
customers and you'll be going over to
the studio in Seattle see you guys later